große Ur heißt einfach nochmal mehr Fläche da rein nehmen, anlegen, sehr, sehr große
Sinkwerte, also wirklich sehr, sehr hohe Sinkwerte, schon bereits in gerade Auszug mit ein
bisschen Rollen und Körperverlagung bringen wir da Werte im 2-stelligen Bereichen, also sehr
einfach und das ohne große körperliche Belastung.
Ist aber jetzt eher eine Fortgeschrift dann erweitig, also das machen wir dann erst um Ende
der Ausbildung.
Prusentlich möchte ich euch aber, auch das mit auf dem Weg geben, weil auch das eine Variante
ist und wirklich wird vernichten, wenn es dann unbedingt Zeitung ist.
Die Technik ist praktisch identisch, so kleine Noren anlegen, nur dass wir jetzt 2 A
in einem rechten Weg nehmen.
Also, wir gehen auch wieder her, bremsel bleibt umstehig in der Hand, warum, das ist natürlich
zum Aufbunden, also wir müssen immer ein bisschen bereit sein für das Ganze, deshalb
behalten wir die bremsel in der Hand, nimmt er den bescheuniger her, auch da wieder leicht
bescheunigen, sehme frisch und jetzt ist wichtig, jetzt müssen wir probieren, die äußerste
A-Leine zu nehmen, rechts und die daneben stehen der A-Leine und wir dürfen jetzt nicht
so weit unten ziehen.
Also, nicht zu nah am Leidenschloss, weil sonst ziehen wir die innerste A-Leine mit und haben
einen kompletten Einklapper, also ein Frontklapper.
Und deshalb müssen wir probieren, möglichst hoch zu greifen, also hoch über das Leinen
Schloss, dann haben wir zuerst abknicken und dann runterziehen, und dann geben wir auf Gas.
Sollten jetzt die Oven sogar fest angelegt sein, können wir ein bisschen nach oben gehen und
ein bisschen weniger Oren anlegen und so die Oren größer sogar ein bisschen einstellen,
dann vielleicht sogar festhalten nach dem Ort, wo wir seid, oder wir können sie so behalten
je nachdem einfach fixieren, am Haupttrag, so nah wie es geht, dann mit der Körpferververlagung
und je nachdem die Sinkgeschwindigkeit erhöhen oder auch nicht, den Jempo gerade behalten,
aber mit vollem Befläunen nicht auch.
Und erst wenn die Oven draußen sind, gehen wir wieder ganz raus auf die Sinkgeschwindigkeit.
Eigentlich wie sie, und muss es nur ein paar mal machen, nicht erschrecken, am Anfang wird
sehr viel Fläche eingeklappt und das kann dazu führen, dass wir da ein bisschen schockiertes
am Anfang, aber wir train, haben das ganze am paar mal und entscheidend ist einfach, dass wir auch
versucht nach oben zu blicken und zu schauen, wie viel habe ich jetzt eingeklappt, wenn es zu viel wäre
und der Schirm praktisch gar nicht richtig geöffnet ist in der Mitte, lassen wir die A-Linen etwas
frei und haben so natürlich nachat, ein bisschen mehr Spierung um den Schirm überhaupt zu steuern
und auf Richtung und Kurs zu weit.